the difference is consensus takes a long
long time you may never actually reach
it so there's always even it's very
interesting because I work with in a
coalition within a coalition so I have
to manage two different coalition
strategies so you have EAC which has a
lot of more mainstream organizations and
then you have a JCC which has a lot of
social justice in environmental justice
organizations so at times the EAC might
want to move on a legislation or
supporting something or calling for
something with our lobby days or
whatever and so we have to make sure
that we're going back to the EJ
community especially our elders in the
community and listening to them and
seeing ok what do you all think about
this situation so for me as someone who
was young and coming into this right at
a college it was the best experience
because I was able to get a broader
perspective of the environmental
movement because i have my ej folk over
here who are in the trenches in the
grass roots and then you have your
policy wonky like Alliance for climate
protection you know Apollo like those
type of groups that are really into
policy and debate and stuff like that
and I can see it from both sides so but
one thing I think it's interesting is
that often times that voice of the
grassroots person isn't heard is not
heard but then gradually later on that
policy person will retrack what they
said and go right with what the
grassroots person was saying and so as
my duty as a young leader I feel like
having the opportunity to work with so
many grassroots organizations and aging
organizations makes me realize the
relevance of listening to these
different groups and I think that every
movement should start from the people
who are impacted and listen from to them
first before they decide on policies and
agendas that are going to set the future
for everyone
on different days it takes different
roles i would say I some days I feel
like I'm the the mother hen or the the
ethical leader so at times people come
to me they're like this going on that's
going on and like ah ah so sometimes I
feel like I have to I feel more
comfortable defending the rights of
others and I do myself so when that
happens I'm like I need to go we need to
rush rah we like you don't feel
supported what am I going to do to make
sure you feel supported and that's what
I think what type of leader I've had to
be um and I've been for a while and now
I'm just kind of looking at it like
along with the ethical aspect of wanting
to do right by my people and knowing
that that is my goal of any work that I
do is to support my people my family my
community my culture I think it's very
important but I also realize that if I
just stood on my ethics and didn't have
a strategy or a vision I wouldn't be
anything and people need more than just
someone to Rara for them they need also
someone to build that mission and and
then invigorate them to actually want to
go on it and have a broader vision so I
think that's where I would like to see
myself and I don't want to ever lose my
ethical ways or my ability to UM be a
process leader I think those are very
very important skills to have but right
now i think i'm sitting just sitting
around meditating on this bigger vision
that I have and this bigger strategy and
so I'm going to use all these lessons
that I've had to really build that
you